you'll never work in this town again
it's a popular saying in Hollywood where
egos routinely clash these a list stars
seriously upset their directors for one
reason or another let's take a peak the
1991 movie hook was a new take on the
Peter Pan story directed by Steven
Spielberg it starred Robin Williams as
Peter Pan and Julia Roberts as
mischievous fairy Tinker Bell well
America's Sweetheart was reportedly so
difficult to work with the crew
nicknamed her Tinker Hell every time
someone says I do not believe in fairy
somewhere there's a fairy that falls
down dead according to premier magazine
Roberts acted rather strangely on set
the article alleges that she was
sometimes somber sometimes at the near
edge of hysteria People magazine reports
that she'd lock herself in her trailer
for hours according to Steven Spielberg
a biography Roberts indulged in some
truly divalicious behavior - one day she
reportedly showed up late and grandly
announced I'm ready now Spielberg
reportedly replied we're ready when I
say were ready Julia the director later
told 60 minutes that it was an
unfortunate time for us to work together
and it's worth noting they have not
worked together since any future Roman
Polanski film is unlikely to star Faye
Dunaway the oscar-nominated star of his
1974 film Chinatown according to the
book easy riders raging bulls Dunaway
once asked Polanski to help her figure
out her character and he replied say the
words your salary is your motivation on
another occasion Polanski was reportedly
so annoyed by a stray hair on Dunaway's
head that he yanked it out
Dunaway screamed in protest and walked
off the set and Polanski did the same I
don't know what you are talking about
this is the craziest most insane those
are minor spats compared to what
allegedly came next while filming an
emotionally charged scene Polanski
reportedly wouldn't let Dunaway run off
to use the bathroom
so she reportedly peed into a cup and
threw it at him in five easy decades of
biography of Chinatown co-star Jack
Nicholson the actor quipped that Dunaway
demonstrated certifiable proof of
insanity the 2010 action comedy cop-out
centers around two mismatched police
officers played by Bruce Willis and
Tracy Morgan and this unlikely duo bands
together to solve a crime
hilarity theoretically ensues whose cars
this yo mamas what you want angry young
man veteran filmmaker Kevin Smith was
hired to direct and the shoot was
evidently a rough one
Willis reportedly considered Smith a
rookie director who wasn't worthy of
respect
at Macworld 2010 Smith revealed that
Willis constantly questioned his
decisions and during an appearance on
WTF with Marc Maron Smith said of the
shoot yeah it was Chow it was difficult
dude he also said that look I know can
help from this dude whatsoever in his
memoir tough Smith wrote that he turned
out to be the unhappiest most bitter and
meanest emo I have ever met at any job
I've held down and mind you I've worked
at Domino's Pizza according to the
National Enquirer Willis chose to skip
the cop-out rap party perhaps that's for
the best since he missed a poisonous
toast from Smith who reportedly said I
want to thank everyone who worked on the
film except for Bruce Willis who is a it
seems like everyone loves George Clooney
but David O'Russell the director of the
1998 film three kings wasn't always the
biggest fan Clooney was reportedly cast
in the film thanks to a development deal
with Warner Brothers this was evidently
against Russell's wishes who just didn't
think he was right for the part the
director and actor reportedly quarreled
on the regular on one occasion Clooney
thought Russell was being rude to the
assistant director in charge of extras
and things came to a head producer
Charles Roven told The Hollywood
Reporter it looks like he's yelling at
him but he's yelling to be heard and
George comes running over and goes I
told you if you're going to pick on
somebody pick on me and David goes why
don't you just even remember your lines
for once and boom they grab each other
and they're tussling and so I pulled
George away that was it George gave a
slightly different account of events
during a playboy interview where he also
claimed that filming three kings was
truly without exception the worst
experience of my life was the President
Bush it sounds like Clooney and Russell
have since made amends in 2012 Russell
told the New York Times George and I had
a friendly reporter last year I don't
know if we would be working together I
don't think we would rule it out Edward
Norton and first time feature director
Tony Kaye had a prickly relationship
while shooting the 1998 drama American
History X but they really started
fighting during post-production keep
your head up all right things are gonna
be fine
It's Me fun
they'll turn that paper after turning in
a rough cut of the movie kay wanted to
keep editing the film until it was just
under 90 minutes but Norton thought he
cut too much and effectively ruined the
movie so he lobbied the studio to let
him recut the film the rough cut was
sent to film festivals angering Kay as
he writes in The Guardian I was shooting
a commercial in Germany when I heard
American History X had been accepted so
I jumped on a plane to Canada marched
into the office of the festival
organizer and demanded that the film be
withdrawn because I wasn't happy with it
new line went nuts kay subsequently
asked the Directors Guild to remove his
name from American History X and instead
credit the film to Humpty Dumpty they
did not oblige his request Norton and
editor Jerry green Burt were ultimately
allowed to recut the film and that's the
version that was ultimately released to
theaters Norton basically got his way
prompting Kaye to take out several ads
and Hollywood trade papers that sharply
criticized the actor kay has also
claimed that Norton is a narcissistic
dilettante obsessed with his image
obsessed with screen time Wes Anderson's
films have a very specific style full of
whimsy 60s British rock and a troop of
unofficial regulars
Bill Murray Angelica Houston Owen Wilson
and Jason Schwartzman are just a few of
the performers who often show up in
Anderson productions and then there's
gene Hackman who only appeared in one
Anderson movie The Royal Tenenbaums are
you trying to steal my woman and thank
you so far he's the only actor who's
ever won a major award for starring in
an Anderson film in 2002 he won the
Golden Globe for Best Actor for a
Musical or Comedy it's rather ironic
when you consider the fact that Anderson
and Hackman were reportedly at odds
while making the movie at a tenth
anniversary celebration of the Royal
Tenenbaums
at the 2011 New York Film Festival
Anderson said he was scared of Hackman
meanwhile Huston quipped
I was
scared but I was more concerned with
protecting Wes she revealed that none of
the cast had seen Hackman since making
the film and claimed that the actor once
told Anderson pull up your pants and act
like a man
Anderson did make a point to say Hackman
is a huge force and I really enjoyed
working with him even though he was very
challenging with me it was very exciting
seeing him launch into these scenes
Anderson and Hackman would never work
together again
and the latter retired from acting in
2004 Marlon Brando reportedly refused to
learn his lines for the island of dr.
Moreau instead a crew member fed him his
dialogue through a radio earpiece
meanwhile his co-star Val Kilmer was
reportedly also causing plenty of
headaches behind the scenes he allegedly
didn't like Richard Stanley's creative
vision and consistently undermined the
director according to The Telegraph on
the rare occasions any filming took
place Kilmer was rude and abrasive
during one scene he reportedly sat on
the ground and refused to stand up his
input certainly contributed to Stanley
being fired early on in the shoot
Stanley subsequently told The Telegraph
Val would have never acted up if the
people around him hadn't kept saying yes
to him all he had to do was make a
demand and the company would give it to
him
Stanley's replacement John Frankenheimer
was hired partly because his tough
reputation made him a good candidate to
control Kilmer in Brando but it didn't
work he was so busy trying to control
Brando and Kilmer that he passed off
directing duties to the film's animal
behavior consultant for a bit
Frankenheimer later told Entertainment
Weekly I don't like Val Kilmer and I
don't want to be associated with him
ever again the film collaborations of
Harold Ramis
and Bill Murray defined comedy for a
generation Ramos helped create classic
Murray comedies like meatballs
Caddyshack stripes and ghostbusters
unfortunately shooting the 1993 classic
comedy Groundhog Day reportedly
destroyed the duo's professional and
personal relationship
26 what do you say you say little brat
you have never thanked me according to
the book Ghostbusters daughter life with
my dad
Harold Ramos by violet Ramos steel Marie
was having some problems in his personal
life at the time she writes that he and
my dad were not seeing eye-to-eye on the
tone of the film during one argument
Ramos reportedly grabbed Marie by the
collar and threw him against the wall
after production on Groundhog Day ended
marie and ramos didn't speak for more
than 20 years
Ramos told The AV Club in 2009 I've had
many dreams about him that were friends
again the filmmaker reportedly tried to
get in touch with Marie over the years
but to no avail
fortunately it sounds like Marie
ultimately made amends
shortly before Ramos is death in 2014
Marie showed up at his house Stihl
writes that Marie arrived unannounced at
7:00 a.m. with a police escort and a
dozen donuts they spent a couple hours
together laughed a little and made their
peace in 1989 and 1990 John Hughes wrote
back-to-back Christmas comedies National
Lampoon's Christmas vacation and home
alone Hughes produced Christmas vacation
offering directing duties to Chris
Columbus in 2015 Columbus told Chicago
magazine I love Christmas so to do a
Christmas comedy had been a dream before
production began Columbus reportedly
went out to dinner with Chevy Chase
the actor who played Clark Griswold in
the first two vacation films a role he
would reprise for Christmas vacation one
year membership in the jelly of the
Month Club okay Clark that's the gift
that keeps on giving the whole year the
meeting didn't go well as Columbus tells
Chicago to be completely honest
Chevy treated me like dirt but Columbus
really wanted that directing job he put
up with the actors hostility long enough
to film some shots of downtown Chicago
the footage made it into the final cut
of the film but Columbus didn't wind up
directing Christmas vacation he tells
Chicago I had another meeting with Chevy
and it was worse I called John and said
there's no way I can do this movie I
know I need to work but I can't
do it with this guy Hughes allowed
Columbus to back out of Christmas
vacation
two weeks later Hughes sent Columbus the
script for home alone and he directed
that instead
John carnies 2013 film begin again stars
Mark Ruffalo as a down-on-his-luck music
executive who launches the career of a
budding singer/songwriter played by
Keira Knightley in 2016 Carney told the
independent Mark Ruffalo is a fantastic
actor alas his praise didn't extend
tonight Lee in fact his comments about
the actress were downright rude at one
point he says I learned that I'll never
make a film with supermodels again
Kyra's thing is to hide who you are and
I don't think you can be an actor and do
that he goes on to say I don't want to
rubbish Kira but you know it's hard
being a film actor and it requires a
certain level of honesty and self
analysis that I don't think she's ready
for yet and I certainly don't think she
was ready for on that film elsewhere in
the interview he says Kira has an
entourage that follows her everywhere so
it's very hard to get any real work done
I think the real problem was that Kira
wasn't a singer and wasn't a guitar
player and it's very hard to make music
seem real if it's not with musicians
you're not a samurai or songwriter a
couple days later carnie apologized to
Knightley in a statement that read in
part I said a number of things about
Kira which were petty mean and hurtful
Kira was nothing but professional and
dedicated during that film and she
contributed hugely to its success I
wrote to Kira personally to apologize
but I wanted to publicly and
unreservedly apologize to her fans and
friends that said carnie hasn't worked
with the actress ever since check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]